bonjour a nice c'est dans maintenant
deux heures que va se terminer le fief
le festival international de l'enfance
et de la jeunesse un festival qui bien
que n'étant pas organisé parmi les
manifestations officielles de l'année
internationale de l'enfant a réuni tout
ce qui pouvait vous intéressez vous les
jeunes
ainsi pour une semaine le palais des
expositions de nice fut transformée en
véritable terrain d'aventuré où poésie
théâtre sports télévision bande dessinée
attendait les jeunes
la musique était présente sous plusieurs
formes avec notamment la présentation
des livres disques pour enfants
collection qui ont pour objectif de
développer le goût de la connaissance
par la lecture l'audition est
l'illustration que ce soit pour
connaître l'avis des grands musiciens
les contes et légendes ou encore
retrouver les héros dans un tel festival
il était normal de consacrer une place
importante à la bande dessinée dans les
personnages ils sont partout présents
dans la ville
l'école de la bd permettait de dialoguer
avec des dessinateurs tels sabari maric
jean claude michel de la fosse fait
manger du savon de marseille à l'âge de
20 ans les bulls automatiquement général
c'est une très belle image
quand on connaît le succès des concours
de dessins que nous organisons à votre
intention
on comprend votre attirance pour les
stands d'animations sur le dessin ou
encore la fabrication des masques
deux cas
d'habitude à quoi ça
je n'ai jamais fait
nancy a mal on l'a
et que tu pratiques où j'étais cours de
tomates
entièrement alors agité les cheveux
s'initie à la télévision à la vidéo
voilà encore une expérience qu'il était
possible de réaliser que ce soit devant
ou derrière la caméra ou encore assis au
pupitre de régis à la plage du
réalisateur votre sécurité n'étaient pas
oubliés avec la visite de la maison type
où tout ce qui est dangereux été signalé
mais aussi avec la connaissance des
premiers gestes qui sauvent
vos cheveux narines
suppl 1
et tout en insufflant on regarde de
l'imposition de la patrie
avec les associations sportives locales
et départementales
l'initiation et la démonstration dans
les principales disciplines musique
encore avec la découverte des
instruments ou des concerts comme celui
donné par leur caisse d'enfants de
l'ohvn but
un festival qui fut pour tous l'occasion
de s'interroger sur les jeunes
ainsi dave qu'attend il exactement de
l'année de l'enfance
non
également les questions est quand même
extrêmement grave et sont malades me
faudra une heure pour répondre mais et
puis ça dépend aussi où sont les enfants
parce que nous avons un problème
sûrement pour les enfants dans notre
monde occidental qui est maintenant un
problème de communes communication entre
déjà les parents les enfants problème de
la télévision puisqu'elle y est est ce
que les enfants alice toujours il ya
tout ce problème n'a et puis à tous ses
autres enfants qui ont des problèmes
beaucoup plus graves beaucoup pourtant
est-ce qu'ils ont seulement à manger
nous on a on n'a peut-être pas là je
crois quand même les premiers question
qu'il faut se poser pour les enfants en
général c'est donner l'heure à manger
tous la faim dans le monde la pollution
la protection des animaux
autant de grands problèmes que les
jeunes des neuf pays de la communauté
ont évoqué dans la grande salle du
conseil municipal de nice lors de la
réunion du parlement européen des jeunes
et cela à quelques mois des premières
élections créant un véritable parlement
européen dans l'europe des neuf
mais à côté des problèmes sérieux
n'oublions pas que le fief c'était aussi
et avant tout la fête des enfants
d